do we really need more toxic post baby
bounceback
[Music]
content hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to aby's Kitchen in today's
video we'll be heading back to the
classic what aena day review style
taking a look at what Victoria Secret
model romance stride eats in a day don't
forget to hit up my description for my
disclaimer and my free Hunger crushing
combo ebook for some balanced meal and
snack ideas and I would also love if you
would hit that subscribe button plus
like and comment it really does help my
videos reach the people who need it most
I want to quickly hop in here to tell
you about today's sponsor blueland so I
know we're just months away from another
set of lofty New Year's resolutions but
I have to say this was one of the first
years that I feel like I actually made
some progress on mine so this year I
made a number of sustainability efforts
I have been composting I I switch to All
glass products over Plastics I've been
buying as much as I can from local Farm
stands and markets and I switch to using
Bland cleaning products so Bland's
dishwasher and laundry tablets are a
planetf friendly cleaning option because
there is no plastic waste most detergent
pods are wrapped in plastic Bland uses
no single-use plastic in any component
and all refills are 100% plastic free
they're also hyperallergenic which is
really important to me because me and my
boys have really sensitive skin and most
importantly they actually work the
dishwasher tablets work without any kind
of rinse aid and the laundry tablets
have lifted all of my boy grass and food
stains and trust me there's a lot of
those and because we do a lot of laundry
and dishes over here I set up a
subscription which are fully
customizable and cost effective so if
you're looking for a more eco-friendly
cleaning option check out my link in the
description to get 15% off of your first
order thank you again to Bland for
sponsoring this video If you're looking
for a more eco-friendly cleaning option
check out my link in the description to
get 15% off of your first kit okay
breaking news here folks the Victoria
Secret show is apparently coming back
TBD if they're going to be going back to
their seemingly dated fantasy body
aesthetic or if they're going to attempt
to play in the inclusive sandbox with
competitors like Ary and Savage by Fenty
you pay me in
advance also TBD if our Victoria Secret
model turned YouTuber turned Bama 2 Rome
is going to be involved in it in any
capacity and if that's in any way a
motivator for her to get back in shape
but whatever the motivation for said
body goals let's take a listen to what
Rome says about hers I've called this
video what I eat in a day to get back in
shape with shape is obviously different
for everyone and with shape I meant the
shape where I feel best so I actually
really appreciate the disclaimer here I
mean sure it may still be very
triggering to to a lot of moms who see
this and think holy sh this girl gave
birth less than a year ago and this is
her second baby she looks way better
than I ever did years after I gave birth
to my first Etc but I believe in body
autonomy and I do at least think it's a
gentle reminder that everyone's journey
is unique yes post baby bounceback
culture is toxic AF but that doesn't
mean that taking any efforts to feel
more like yourself post baby is Rome is
also a model so her business is quite
literally her business card so I really
don't blame or shame her for wanting to
take any efforts to feel and look her
best I mean as long as she's not sharing
crazy dangerous cleanses or diets or
detoxes to do it in front of her very
vulnerable young audience I think we're
already a few steps ahead those
sleepless nights are rough and let me
tell you you want Comfort F when you
like sleep so little yep you do and
there's actually a scientific reason for
that so rear suggest suest that when
you've underslept your hunger hormone
grin Rises and your satiety hormone
leptin plummets but you're not just
hungry for carrots and hummus usually
you're reaching for those Feelgood carb
Rich Comfort foods that Romy described
and this is related to an increase in
endocannabinoids when you're feeling
sleep deprived so endocannabinoids bind
to the same receptors as the active
ingredient in marijuana which as a lot
of us know often triggers the munchies
hey man
am I driving
okay I think we're parked man and
researchers believe that circulating
levels of these compounds specifically
make us crave highly palatable fatty
starchy sugary Foods people on shift
works or new moms or folks who have
struggled with insomnia can all attest
that getting sleep makes it really hard
to eat well but as every mother-in-law
loves to remind us this Phase 2 shall
pass
I'm trying to balance it out with those
days with healthy days and this is an
example of a day where I try to eat
healthy but this is not what I eat every
day obviously so again I appreciate this
disclaimer because you know I just think
it's important for new moms to know that
it's not realistic to cook every meal
from scratch every day I mean I would
still personally love to see more real
mom life food content here where you
know there's like a balance of eating
some convenience foods and carrying a
baby on your hip and maybe throwing a
vertisserie chicken on a plate with some
BS lettuce and calling it lunch but at
least we've got the memo that this is
part reality and part fantasy so don't
feel so bad if you can't keep up because
I sure as didn't and I already put some
Black Coffee in there with ice cubes and
I'm adding oat
milk there is so much Internet Hate
around oat milk in coffee these days
like I'm shocked the anti o trolls
having like flocked to R's content
section to shame her for her coffee
Choice shut up but first of all you guys
know the rule here in aby's kitchen no
shaming or trying to change how people
take their coffee coffee is sa now
recently I went into detail about why
people are so anxious about oat milk
lattes in my call her daddy video right
here but in short there's a concern that
the combination of sugar in the oat milk
and caffeine in the coffee will cause
raging anxiet
and my response of course was that it's
probably not a huge deal if you're a
regular coffee drinker these effects on
the stress hormone cortisol doesn't seem
to be super significant now
interestingly Roman chose the no sugar
Ole which actually got into some hot
water recently when its competitor
Campbell Soup company issued a complaint
about their dishonest use of the words
no sugar added it is a bit misleading
because while Ole might not add extra
sweeteners to the milk the way that the
oats are processed breaks down the oat
starch into simple sugars like maltos
which results in inevitably free or
added sugar and that's probably why they
had to change their marketing to have
the no in big quotations again I don't
think a small amount of sugar here is a
huge deal but if you do experience a
blood sugar Spike from the oat milk
latte or any latte for that matter
because coffee can also transiently
increase our blood sugars it could
easily be mitigated by having it with a
snack or a meal which Rome does so let's
take a look I like to add is like some
goci
berries just put them in there some
almonds and some blueberries and these
are frozen because I've heard frozen
blueberries are healthier than regular
berries so we're using frozen
blueberries okay so this is an amazing
new mom friendly breakfast idea here
because you can make a big batch of this
ahead of time and then you can just like
Chuck whatever toppings you want in
there when it's time to eat it's also
very nutrient dense about 500 calories
with 17 gam each of fiber and protein
chia seeds are super high in fiber and
amazing for supporting regularity so
especially right after you give birth
when things are moving a little slower
down there chia pudding can be super key
as for the Frozen is healthier than
fresh claim yeah that is legit
especially for out of seasoned produce
or produce that is being shipped from
afar one 2014 report found that when
compared to Fresh Produce including
blueberries that sat in the fridge for
just 3 days Frozen packed higher amounts
of antioxidants and polyenals antoin
lutein and Beto carotene Frozen produces
also typically additive and preservative
free super convenient and often cheaper
so yeah we are all team frozen over here
too so here we are we we're making a
post-workout Shake which is very very
easy I have my favorite chocolate
protein from
NES and I'll add in here I'll add a
banana and some frozen blueberries again
then I'll add water and we'll shake it
up this looks like an amazing
post-workout snack so for post-workout
recovery we often want a combination of
protein and carbs without too much fat
to slow down their absorption and this
has a little bit of fiber plus
energizing carbs and an impressive 27 g
of protein which is right in that
optimal range for muscle protein
synthesis and since getting back in
shape is one of Rome's goals we know
that it's advantageous to get at least.
31 G per kilogram of protein per meal so
yeah this shake is definitely Abby
approved okay so here we have a whole
wreath rep um and you can heat it up or
you can eat it cold I love it cool and
we're going to add the the cork
mole and then you f
thex some
f and here we go you roll it up and it's
ready to e we love a EG wrap moment for
lunch this is totally a staple for me
too and this is a really great example
of a hunger crushing combo fber carbs in
the wrap healthy fats in the guac and
protein in the eggs I know I personally
would probably need like two two of
these to feel satisfied and I just share
that in case others are seeing that and
feeling the same but I'm not sure how
close she had the Smoothie to the lunch
so if the portion works for her it works
for me we're going to fruit the onion I
think it's called fruit in English as
well adding some spinach now and I
always add a lot because spinach gets
very small when you heat it up now it's
time to add the rulta cheese okay the
pasta is ready so we're going to add it
in here okay here is the pasta we're
adding the salmon on top and then the
Finishing Touch some pine
nuts and a lot of
bagano this is gorgeous and I would say
relatively simple though admittedly
probably way more ambitious than I would
bring myself to make when I was a year
postpartum never mind today and I'm 3
years out basically I've got like a mom
standard over here that if I spend time
making a ey dish I'm going to take
shortcuts on the main protein or vice
versa but anyway love this journey for
her we got carbs in the pasta fiber in
the spinach plus protein and healthy
fats in the salmon Ricotta and nuts it's
really beautiful I really wouldn't
change a thing so I got to give to Rome
these are really balanced meals for the
days that she's trying to eat healthy I
believe that it doesn't have to be all
or nothing and you know I stand by the
fact that it's probably a lot more
helpful for people watching to get a
glimpse into that combination of seeing
those convenience Comfort foods that she
talks about and the healthy foods that
she shared here a healthy relationship
with food is all about living in the
gray it shouldn't be black or white or
on or off or clean or junk Etc that said
I really do appreciate that even with
the goal to get back in shape Rome
doesn't seem to severely restrict
anything we got five Rich carbs we got
protein we got healthy fats we got it
all and based on my calculations she's
likely consuming an appropriate
sustainable amount of calories for
weight or fat loss rather than like
starving herself on a 12200 calorie diet
like so many other Wellness influencers
or new moms so yeah this day looked
amazing and was definitely inspiring and
I really wish roate all the best as a
mama to it's only uphill from here I
mean unless you try for number three
which I won't and on that note that's
all that I have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on who or what you'd like to see your
viiew next hit up the description for my
free Hunger crushing combo ebook and I
will see you next time on aby's kitchen
[Music]
bye